moi je suis très frappé de voir que
cette politique qui a consisté à être
anti nucléaires qui a reposé sur des
mensonges parce que les antinucléaires
ont réussi à faire croire aux français
que le nucléaire rejeter beaucoup de co2
on a des enquêtes qui montre que 85 %
des français sont persuadés que le
nucléaire rejette beaucoup de co2 d'où
ça vient ça vient de ce que les
gouvernements et surtout les écologistes
ont répété ce mensonge si souvent qu'ils
ont réussi à convaincre les français de
ce qui est une inexactitude évidente que
même monsieur bourg reconnaîtra comme
tel mais pour revenir au nucléaire il ya
un point qui est très frappant c'est que
la france est en train de perdre pied
complètement les pays qui actuellement
produisent du nuc les centrales
nucléaires c'est la chine
c'est la russie qui est le premier
exportateur de nucléaire dans le monde
c'est la corée ça n'est plus la france
et il ya là quelque chose qui est
particulièrement triste parce que c'est
l'un des fleurons de la science et de la
technologie française qui est étranglé
par les amis de monsieur hulot
[Musique]